one of my favorite aspects of the Reuben
report is the feedback that we're
getting from viewers literally all over
the world just last week I had viewers
from countries like Egypt Denmark Mexico
Spain and Australia reach out to me just
to name a few
I'm truly humbled that so many of you
take the time to share your feelings
with me and although I don't have time
to respond to everyone I do try to at
least read the messages that you're
sending to me the most amazing part of
this is that the conversations we're
having on this show are transcending
race religion sexuality and Nationality
the fight for free speech the importance
of not giving in to the authoritarians
and the awakening against the
regressives are all ideas that bring us
together the power of ideas is universal
when we discuss free speech free thought
and free expression it's vital that we
mean it equally for everyone not just in
an identity politics based pecking order
this device this thing that we all have
in our pocket is bringing us closer
together in ways that we're literally
unimaginable only a generation ago
right this very second one of you is
watching this direct message while on
the subway in New York City one of you
is listening to the podcast while at the
gym in London and one of you is
streaming this while on your couch in
Moscow not only are you all tuning in on
a variety of platforms but you're
furthering the discussion of these ideas
on Facebook and Twitter or just by
talking with your friends and family
that expansion of our conversations
makes me want to do better work even if
talking about difficult topics comes at
both a personal and professional cost as
the world has gotten smaller it has
never been more important to hear voices
the challenge our thinking and give
unique perspective based on their own
personal story my guest this week is
inna Shevchenko inna is the leader of
the women's movement femen International
a columnist for the International
Business Times and a free-speech
activist she was born in Ukraine in the
same year that the USSR fell has been
kidnapped by the Belarus KGB and in 2013
was granted political asylum in France
she has lived a truly controversial life
and paid the price for being outspoken
more than once this is not some
who only talks about the news this is
someone who actually lives it there are
many issues I want to discuss with ena
from women's rights and free speech to
Islamism and political correctness but I
also want to talk to her about life in
France right now has it changed since
the Paris terror attacks what's the
political climate has the regressive
mentality steeped into the mainstream
thus weakening free speech and helping
the authoritarians
the only way we can find answers to
questions like these is to be connected
with people who aren't afraid to share
their views you know there's a catch-22
to all this connectivity as it brings us
closer and transcends cultures and
borders it can also make everyone else's
problems seem like our own on one hand
we can see how others live and have
empathy for our fellow man on the other
hand sometimes it's hard to gauge just
how much something across the globe
should affect us in our day-to-day lives
I try to do this show each week in the
spirit of finding balance between those
two concepts and I hope you know will
provide perspective on some of the big
questions I've mentioned here the more
we focus on our common humanity the less
chance we'll be able to be ripped apart
inna Shevchenko is the leader of the
international women's movement FEMEN a
writer a speaker and a fearless free
speech advocate inna welcome to the show
hello hi thank you for an invitation
yeah well I'm really glad that we
connected I've known about your work for
a while and then I saw a piece that you
wrote in the International Business
Times last week about the regressive
left and the racist right and that
basically most of us are in-between and
that's very much what what we've been
talking about here on this show so I
thought it would be a perfect time to
talk to you so you're you're in Austria
right now is that right I'm right now in
Austria yes yes right can I ask what
you're doing there or is this a
top-secret mission yeah no I'm here for
a conference about free speech of course
I hope that this time it will not be
interrupted by a terrorist we will be
speaking and enjoy this topic discussing
this topic all right well we're gonna
talk about some of the interruptions
that you've had by terrorists when
you're giving talks
free speech but first let's do a little
bit on your biography because I think
it's pretty amazing I mentioned at the
top of the show you were born in Ukraine
not the Ukraine you were born in Ukraine
the same year that the Soviet Union fell
and I think that had a lot to do with
sort of your your path right now because
of things that you saw in a sort of
newborn country so can you talk a little
bit about your history first well right
I was born the year my country was born
actually yeah and of course the
situation you know for me as a child for
me it was just just a childhood but for
adults it was of course a rough reality
and then later I understood that I had a
rough childhood however you know for me
to make a home work under the candles
because all electricity in the city was
shot for the sake of economy you know we
didn't have we didn't have a national
currency and my parents were receiving
celery with sausages or with bread you
know and yeah I mean poverty I'm poverty
was poverty you know and I think that
this is not something special for ya to
tell you about it because still until
today many people live in party and 25
years after Ukraine well actually right
now in the similar situation and you
know already my nephew a small child who
is eight years old he lives nearly a
similar situation and has similar
childhood to what I had so situation is
not really changing and progressing but
of course it had a really huge impact on
me and I think on all generation that
was born of the collapse of USSR because
we saw well we saw that you know as
adults were saying our country was ruled
by 450 idiots
this is I'm quoting yeah particular yeah
my grandma and my mother they were
calling them well all adults were
calling politicians always you know
there was always this clear gap between
society
and those 450 idiots again as they say
there was always a gap between
government and and actually citizens and
you could you know as a child I never
could imagine that there could be any
connection between those people between
this small group of people that we could
call 1% and 99 percent of population
there was always an impression as if we
were living in different countries I saw
of course you know I grew up in a very
traditional society where woman has to
work and well to have job and also of
course take care of everything at home
and even though my father was not a
particular patriarch but of course all
while my mother was housewife as well as
working full-time and in 90s during well
during this time of you know trying to
create a government in the country after
collapse of USSR parents had to work on
different jobs and my mother was working
on three different jobs and of course
taking care of us at home which of
course gave an impression and kind of
you know yeah well yeah we had a painted
picture of what woman is supposed to do
and what her mission is and what
municipal to do and even in such a hard
economically time my father was of
course earning much more and had access
to more jobs and could good yeah had
possibility to find different jobs more
interesting than my mother women really
were doing two jobs because they were
working and they were taking care of the
home and the kids and all that yeah yeah
I think it's incorrect to speak in the
past because as I already said it
remains the reality is still exactly the
same and maybe sometimes we have an
illusion you know expect in a different
cover and we can see more women who do
not do that however still majority of
women live that life and my mother still
continues to work it to different jobs
today and well she doesn't have children
anymore we are going right so I don't
think you think there is anything wrong
with
in and of itself you just sort of want
people to acknowledge the role of the
woman right what do you mean I don't
think well that they're doing that
they're doing both these things that
they it's not bad to take care of your
kids in and of itself right it's not bad
to take care of your kids but it's bad
if you're the only ones supposed to take
care of your kids right so the role the
role well yeah exactly that you have to
follow the role and you have no choice
and I think I think there's a lot of
things that are wrong in this in this
concept and in this reality and
therefore we yeah we started our
movement in Ukraine as a women's
movement feminist movement even though
at the beginning I should confess when
we started our activity we didn't really
had a clear understanding what feminism
was about because for example to give
you yet to give you an example I was
studying in the best university of
Ukraine I was studying journalism and in
four years of my studies I never had
even even one hour lecture on what
feminism is well I didn't even hear the
definition of such ideology because that
was something which is not close to
Eastern European society again where
women have to be at home and take care
of who are of family but not going to
street and demand their rights actually
it's not concerning only women's rights
but generally I grew up in the country
where people do not until 2008 a 2004
sorry at the moment of Orange Revolution
the first revolution that happened in
the history of independent Ukraine until
that moment people didn't have a you
know to protest was a you know an
activity of a bad taste Smoove aigoo you
know it was something that you wouldn't
do it was something that you would do
only to probably earn money because
political parties in Ukraine pay you for
standing with their flags and the street
and protesting supporting one or another
politician so when we started our
activity we were of course accused -
accused for being paid
by someone and being political project
or also being named by our parents or
relatives who knew that we don't get
money for that we would just simply
named either witches work
psychologically sick girls right okay so
I don't want to jump too far ahead yet
so we're gonna we're gonna go into we're
gonna go into all that but just to sort
of wrap up the Ukraine part because I
think a lot you know there's so much
happening with Ukraine and as you said
it is a young country it's only 25 years
old in terms of independence what do you
make of what's happening in Ukraine now
because it sort of seems like the the
quest for true independence in a way has
failed because Russia is is back in
Ukraine right so is do you feel like
you're part that Ukraine is really an
independent state at this point
well Ukraine is an independent state and
I think that nobody should question it
well of course
Putin questions I mean Russia is
questioning it yeah but Ukraine is an
independent state of course even though
our territories were already taking an
occupied like Crimea work was recently
occupied and Ukraine lost it right now
and still there is the eastern part of
Ukraine occupied by Russian military
troops and I will say it bravely I will
claim that their Russian troops as it
was proven well Ukraine is an
independent state which is definitely at
the stage of its development and
creation and you know choosing the the
past while 99 percent of population
today are screaming for euro-integration
and for wish to join European Union or a
dream because I think it's quite a dream
not a possibility yet
there is still the garment the one that
I mentioned about 450 inches to remain
they were they remain those people
because well I should say that the
problem of my country what my country
the country where I was born because I
don't feel like I have a country I think
that the problem of this country is that
for 25 years at least I observe the same
faces in the Parliament I hear this
names of politicians it's the country is
ruled by the same if you want you know
mafia oligarch unions fractions and for
example today's President poroshenko who
is you know supposed to be and he claims
to be the one who is for your
integration he was a Minister of Foreign
Affairs in the cabinet in a parliament
of President Yanukovych who was recently
the dictator
against who people went out recently at
the square in Maidan in Kiev so
definitely I should say that this
revolution you know I think that it's
it's intellectually unfair and wrong to
think that after people go out and
assert that revolution is when people go
out in the street well no it's it's
beginning of it it's it's beginning of
the process and I think that the protest
started in 2004 the first orange
revolution ten years after people again
went out in the street because the
changes didn't happen today again many
people are deceived because they don't
see rapid changes but I think that it's
mistaken and wrong to expect changes
right away and I think that I think that
Ukraine will have to will have to have
few more revolutions yeah so speaking of
that do you do you think what is the
average person in Ukraine feel about how
the rest of the world views them now
because I sense that the people of
Ukraine want more help from the West and
that you know in America we talk about
it you know we talked about it for like
the two weeks that Putin was moving
troops in or whatever it was there was a
two week window where we talk about it
now it just we just completely forget
about it is there a disappointment on
behalf of the people sort of how the the
world has reacted to what's happened
there well of course yes there is a
disappointment because you know people
feel that people know that their garment
is actually unable to do something to
change something and since people give
you know from this Square in Maidan they
were giving the messages to the world of
course they do expect from other states
more powerful or so-called Democratic
who
reached a certain level who could help
and support and especially those who
supported verbally but do not support
support practically of course many
people are as I said deceived and
disappointed today and even some come to
the point when they say that with
Yanukovych with the dictator
it was battle because at least we had
what to eat and he did his garment
didn't touch yeah so so last thought on
this and then we're gonna move on to
some of the feminism stuff I mean wasn't
and correct me if I'm wrong but I think
didn't Ukraine have nukes which they
gave up as part of that they would get
NATO protection once they were an
independent nation and basically that
just didn't happen right so they sort of
gave up their protection though the
weapons that would have protected them
and then they get this invasion or
whatever you want to call it from Russia
and now the other countries right there
are doing nothing we're doing nothing so
it was it was really like an unfortunate
decision I suppose well right now
discussing about decision or NATO I
think it will be because well there are
a lot of sides of this question but yes
this is what happened and of course many
people today thinking back and think
that what kind of mistakes were done but
at that moment it seemed to be a very
correct decision because you know nobody
could expect that Putin would suddenly
decide to occupy the territories and
prove the world that he's even bigger
dictator than
already the world perceive him hey well
I know we can talk about that political
stuff forever so let's let's move on to
the stuff that you're really passionate
about and it's funny because at the top
of the show I do my direct message where
I give my feelings of the week and I
wrote my my little piece about it
yesterday and then right after I wrote
it I watched your TED talk and basically
your TED talk was a twenty minute sort
of much broader version of exactly what
I happened to write about yesterday by
total coincidence and I know that the
things that you talk about are the
things that I'm incredibly passionate
about that I've made the show about so
you had a great quote in your in your
TED talk
you said that FEMEN is a movement that
is trying to rebuild society without
permission I love that line so can you
just expand on that a little bit and
what made you start feminine and where
do you think it's going well
particularly about that statement I
should say that anyone who is dreaming
to repeal the world should count that
you know you should not ask for
permission because nobody will ever give
it to you so if you dream to change
something you should not ask for
permission or wait when someone will
give you that perfect I'm right and it
will never happen yes because well in
Ukraine as I said we started in Ukraine
movement in 2008 where exist movement
already exists for 8 years and I should
say that when we started we didn't have
any particular knowledge of you know
political knowledge or didn't know how
to work with media I told you already
that we didn't really have a clear
understanding what feminism is about and
I don't feel embarrassed or shy to say
about that because I think that this
should show and reflect the society in
which we were growing up I remember
joining this little group about which
nobody knew at that moment yet we were
young and we had a meeting in a very
Soviet style a cafe in the center of
Kiev sharing two cups of tea on 54 15 of
us because we were all young students
coming from small cities to Kiev
dreaming that this will be the time the
place where we will have his women
opportunities and the only opportunities
were proposed even in this big city in
capital that looked for us you know huge
tremendous place we we only had
opportunities well similar to those that
I saw opportunities that women had in my
childhood you know to serve someone and
of course very often Ukrainian women are
because many claim that they are
beautiful but what is true there
educated and poor and this becomes a
reason to involve easily involve women
and sexual exploitation prostitution and
of course you know on my way to
university every day I I could be here
first of all harassed second receive
many Flyers from what pimps or brothers
who would propose you to go to work and
many women many girls did go and you
know applied for such a job because you
don't have other possibilities because
you know anything else so for us the
first reason to start our activity was
to fight this disease this illness of
Eastern Europe considering women as sex
slaves as prostitute and we were
campaigning against prostitution and sex
tourism which is really widespread
disease in Ukraine particularly and we
were campaigning against that wearing
pink clothes and caring pink balloons
and pink flags believing that with this
pink colours will attract attention to
to this problem however of course we
failed and organizing protests with
100-200 female activists nobody was even
stopping when they were passing by to
read our banners and we were in search
of tactics of the ways how we can
attract attention of this very a
political again desperate society to
something very essential to the rights
of women something that the whole world
is already talking about accepting
changing you know adopting laws and yeah
well for two years we we were in this
desperate search and in 2010 we saw that
the situation in Ukraine was changing
because the dictator which we understood
later dictator Yanukovych was elected as
a president and the situation was
changed you could immediately feel the
censorship in media you could
immediately feel the change of political
situation and the mood in the country
and we understood that we probably have
to go as a female activists as female
voices will probably have to campaign
about some something broader something
that brings us to this problem you know
more limited problems such as
prostitution and sex tourism something
that is you know to the root of the
problem the political situation the
economical situation those people who
bring the society in such state so we
did our first topless protests 2010 to
be honest it was more as an experiment
it was also sort of a scream from inside
and as I said it was it was you know a
decision made during this you know being
in a very in a desperate search of how
to let people hear women's voices and
their problems how did that first moment
feel for you when you did the topless
protests cuz you guys even if it hadn't
picked up much traction you were already
talking about things as you've said that
were sort of not accepted in your
society so you're already going against
the grain but then yeah you realized
alright we've got to do something that's
gonna really get us publicity the right
way and all that
how did literally that first moment when
you took off your top feel huge
discussion in them in the group well
sort of in a fight about whether to do
it or not because and I was one of those
who were against topless protests so
that came later for me but definitely it
had a huge effect because we now we not
only had an unpopular speech but we also
used and very unpopular tactic we were
showing something image of a woman which
is very unpopular in this society the
image a woman which was popular in
Ukraine was the you know a nice smiling
sexy cleaning lady but we were showing a
screaming and greed bare breasted woman
was the message was slogan written
across her chest which was something
that was
breaking completely the definition you
know there yeah the definition or
imagination the the context in which
people could see the woman and the
definition of woman in generally in
Ukraine and of course it was it attract
a lot of attention different attention
as well as some support very small
support from Ukraine and of course we
felt a huge support from abroad and a
lot of criticism of course of course we
will be named prostitutes immediately
because we were naked which again
revealed something that for people you
know naked were human is equal to
prostitute and actually I should say
that so is this topless protests what we
are reaching I think that we are
committing sort of a test for democracy
we commit tests which we test the
society and with this tactic with the
messages and speeches that we have we
test society and we reveal a lot we
reveal a lot on the reaction on those
protests so I should say that what we
actually do very often people say famine
are violent because we are aggressive
because we are screaming so which
immediately feel it for people you know
a woman who is angry in the violence is
something violent we you find to see
angry man but well woman which is not
smiling or keeping silent but who
screaming is something violent we got
out there people well we probably kill
you we're probably feeling some people
by our messages I mean of course
literally we do not harm who do not we
do not interact you know we we don't
touch anyone physically we can touch and
attack ideas we buy our ideas but what
actually do is we appear take off our
top and strip our ID is written on our
bodies we create I think that we
transform our bodies in the political
messages in our manifesto in posters if
you want they
these are our posters on which we write
our slogans and I think this way we I
think it's kind of general a few
functions because first function of
course is to provoke to attract
attention second is that we change the
meaning of what naked body is it's not
you know you there's so many you can see
women naked women everywhere on covers
of magazines on Billboard's they are
posing smiling sexy what we are showing
we are showing woman who is not sexy but
you know she's political her body's
political she's not smiling she's
screaming she's not inviting you to use
her she is refusing she is showing her
anger she's showing that she's demanding
something and of course this is
something that breaks a lot of
stereotypes and rules and traditions in
particularly in society like Ukraine now
generally in many countries we received
a very different reaction on such
protests and I think it reveals her a
lot it mirrors a lot well what's
interesting is you're really talking
about the true roots of what feminism
really is you are demanding to be
accepted as an absolute equal to a man
which really is what the first wave
feminism here in the West was it's now
changed and morphed into something else
but all you're demanding sort of is
equality I've seen you described as a
sex streamis do you like that word do
you guys you've used that word a little
bit but I've heard it about you more
well this is the word that we created
actually and weird if I were selfish
sexed remissed because we use our sex
the fact that we are female as our
weapon our bodies are our weapons and I
think this is also sort of an odd answer
to fundamentalist to terrorists who use
the gun hunts who actually kill people
we show them our my body is my weapon
because first of all you are scared of
it as if it was actually a weapon who
which could kill you and the second we
see that this body really can destroy
you know can destroy bad ideas or at
least challenge them will provoke them
and create discussions so yes we call
ourselves extra miss because we use our
sex a is our weapon
our body is our weapon okay so as I
mentioned at the top of the show and as
you've illustrated here quite obviously
it's not just that you talk about these
things but you literally are putting
your life on the line I mean just by
taking your shirt off the amount of
people who you've angered it's it's
incredible it's crazy but you've also
had very close brushes with the law with
actual terrorism and violence can you go
into a couple examples the KGB example
in Belarus and just and and you were
literally an event that you were
speaking about free speech was shot up
and there's some crazy audio of that can
you just talk about those two examples
well yes I think I think this is what I
was talking about that will reveal a lot
of things with this protest but to be
honest we didn't expect that we will you
know just a topless woman with the words
written across her chest could you know
could invite the governments and Secret
Service's to change them arrest them
kidnap them and torture we have been
literally tortured in Belarus after one
of our protests that we staged in
December 2011 which was an anniversary
it was 19 December 2011 anniversary of a
one-year anniversary of a huge
demonstration in the Minsk where during
which many people have been arrested
mainly disappeared and some reportedly
have been killed but the information is
always hidden there and we staged an
ironical protest mocking dictator
Lukashenko in front of KGB office which
is officially official KGB service there
and during the protest journalists have
been grabbed by the staff KGB staff the
man who came out of the office of KGB
and we we were ignored so we could leave
the place they certainly knew that they
will be able to catch us before they
what was important at that moment for
them to stop the journalists from
releasing
the images however some journalists
managed to do it they left before having
experience obviously working in Belarus
and later a few hours after when we were
at the bus station in Minsk on our way
back to Kiev to Ukraine
we have been grabbed and thrown into a
bus in which we spend the whole night
being questioned by men well we saw
their faces they didn't hide themselves
but they were clearly saying that
they're KGB and they were asking us who
paid us for this protest they were
saying that they know that Europe pays
us which is ridiculous you know who is
Europe I was trying to ask them as well
they didn't answer because they were the
ones asking questions so yeah and after
that night we have been brought to a
forest in which we changed their buses
we were taking in another bus and there
there was another troop of men faces of
who we couldn't see anymore because the
plastic handcuffs on our hands and we
were not allowed to move and had to keep
our heads down and looking on the floor
well we heard during I think 5/6 hours
drive we heard that we will be killed
we heard the description you know
different description of how we can be
killed and we were asked to breathe loud
because they wanted to hear us breathing
saying that in few hours we will not be
able to breathe they were saying that
they will send our corpse of parts of
our bodies to our mothers and so on and
so forth which was of course the done
very professionally you know you could
feel that this man do this every day is
their job actually to torture people
like that um we received few hits but
they were not beating us severely but
later we were taking out of the bus in a
forest and there they were they were
doing horrible things such as putting
you know Gaza
on us and playing very you know coming
with a fire very close to the body so
you feel like you would they will burn
you alive right now yeah they made us
undress you know turn and so they were
creating situations when you feel like
next second they will rape you they will
burn you that will kill you they will
cut you you know what they did they cut
my hair was nice they were you know they
throw some you know green antiseptic in
my face which I couldn't wash away you
know like things that was somehow at
some point would sound it's ridiculous
but it was it was it's torture it was
psychological and physical torture they
were filming everything on two video
cameras so it was supposed to be
reported to someone and we so 15 men
around us and masks and the fact that
they were wearing masks made me think
that they will not kill us because they
hide their faces however I didn't know
how far they will go in their action and
they after this torture they throw us
out of the forest and we spent another
five hours six hours to find someone and
we found a village a village it's a big
word probably for seven houses you know
in the middle of the forest we found and
we were lucky enough that at that moment
there was someone who came from the city
and had mobile phone and of course for
24 hours already all at least
russian-speaking world was searching for
us and information was spread everywhere
and we easily contacted our colleagues
and journalists and later four hours
later the ambassador of ukraine arrived
to police station in which we were
staying for some time and it took us
back to Kiev well this is one of the
experience you know in Ukraine also we
constantly were followed by Secret
Service's threatened and well they
opened for criminal cases against us for
hooliganism this is something that
they use in Ukrainian Russia against
political activists for example right
now there was a artist dr. Polanski who
burned the door of Russian Secret
Service and he's also written as a
hooligan while they treat us as a
hooligans because this is something very
vague you know you're right good yeah
you could call anyone who leaked and
yeah and then Ukraine after our first
and very loud protest against union of
church and state I had to flee I had to
leave the country because well literally
I had to jump out from the window of my
apartment jump in the car and run away
um when this stuff is happened to I mean
I know you can you have so many examples
of this which we could you know we can
spend hours talking about but when these
things have happened to you I mean what
happened to you in that farce it sounds
horrific you survived but obviously
their goal is intimidation their goal of
course is to silence you and then by
silencing you they silence your
followers and that's how they they end
you guys they don't have to actually
kill you so I'm curious afterwards after
something like that happens
do you or did you feel alright maybe
we've taken this as far as it should go
me or did it did you immediately double
down and say now we're we're getting
somewhere with this play a superhero and
of course you have all the fear you feel
you feel that I will not write after you
feel I will never do it again but then
you know after some time take thinking
about it and really spending time on
repeating in your mind what really
happened you understand that it's not
it's not us who went too far is their
reaction goes too far probably because
we do something which they don't want to
happen and so it means that we do
something very right and I think of
course again I will never deny that we
have fear we do have fear but I should
say that the fear of the fear of giving
up to those people is much bigger
then fear of being taken to the forest
at least you already know how it feels
and what it is and again your fear it's
a choice right so we probably make a
choice you know not to fear but to deal
with the fear and to continue the
activity because again just think about
how ridiculous actually this all is
there are girls who take off their tops
and write slogans and for that they are
taking to the forest
KGB staff are spending with them 24
hours torturing them and doing all the
insane things how ridiculous this is how
ridiculous is the fact that there are
people planning terrorist attacks taking
guns blowing themselves up because they
want to stop those who draw a card by
caricatures you know who drove very
funny or not funny for some cartoons but
something so peaceful so somehow very
childish as well you know something very
simple so I think that it also reveals a
lot it shows how it shows them yeah how
crippled our society is how the how we
replace the fight or the yeah the fights
of ideas by actually de fight between
people and I think that this is a pretty
reason to continue and you know
sometimes people say well you already do
it for six years and you are only 25 and
you already have been nearly killed at
least three times but what makes you go
on but this actually this is exactly the
reason that make you go go on because
you understand that just because you say
you know you write three words in your
body or you write an article or you draw
a cartoon they want to kill you for that
isn't it ridiculous doesn't it show that
I live in six society and because I
don't want to live in six society I
continue I go on I know that the history
of my time is written right now and well
to let fundamentalist dictators
misogynist to write history of my time
well I don't agree with that I want to
participate writing the history yeah I
mean let's
I love everything that you just said the
whole spirit of everything that I do is
exactly that and you're it you're at the
front lines of it so that's a good segue
actually to in 2013
you got asylum in France and you live in
France now and that must have been an
interesting time to move to France
because shortly after that was the
Charlie Hebdo attacks now you you knew
some of the cartoonists right you had
work with them a little bit so can you
talk about that
well I knew all the cur
those who died and those who survived as
well we had well we were friends we were
really friends and we spend a lot of
time just together debating discussing
and sharing what we shared a lot of
ideas and to be honest when I arrived to
France and after few of protests that we
organized in France and clearly stated
our direct message not message which is
following all the demands of political
correctness
you know unnecessary political
correctness yes in Europe Charlotte they
were the only one who were really on the
same line with us and we became really
your friend and it's very very soon and
we even made one issue of Charlotte
though together with famine and well
yeah and of course we will some time we
were spending reading to each other the
threats that we were receiving and
lovely you know and became fan of the of
the fanatics who were spending time for
writing those threads and you know
writing these speeches which they were
reading recording on our voicemails yeah
and of course losing your friends not
only friends you know yeah not only
friends but ideologic ideological
friends or brothers if you want was of
course was again something which of
course is personally very hard and heavy
shows you again shows you that if you
stop then you will fail and your ideas
will fail
I believe that
it would be it will sound a bit all but
even those cartoonists who died who were
killed they didn't lose and their ideas
you know they are not the ideas are not
failure they they will always remain as
yes and those who continue to do what
they believed in and that what they
believe in is the right thing because
they were not harming anyone they were
contributing to a very important things
such as freedom of expression and they
were contributing to this to keep and
save the values of France as well which
is Liberty Goleta fraternity which is
you know sometimes today you think that
it it remains only on the buildings
written on the buildings but not
actually in life not actually applied in
life of society anymore so Charlie Fodor
heroes a part of being friends they are
heroes however I should also mention
that just the months before what day
they were killed they were racist
Islamophobes you know they they were
always named for being too much for
going too far for offending we all know
that right and just to be very clear I
know this has been said a thousand times
over but they were not racist and they
were not Islamophobes which is a made-up
word by the way but they were not they
were pointing out the they made fun of
everybody and I think something like
it's three percent of the covers were
about Islam but they equally attacked
Christianity and Judaism and all the
religions it was about power so they
were making cartoons about the exact
things that you were protesting in the
streets it was really kind of amazing
but what do you and the fact what you
mentioned just right now that only 3% of
the covers and the the all material in
the newspaper was about Islam also shows
something that we were also discussing
with them often and you know as we
talked about France and things that
happen in France maybe to make sense to
quote Voltaire again here
and this
were attributed to him he said that if
you want to find out who rules over you
simply understand who you are not
allowed to criticize so even this 3% you
know of the of the information or the
the the topic you know Islam um that was
just taking 3% of the of the whole
information of Charlotte though really
shows a lot so that of course is the
youngest from three monotheistic
religions the most ambitious probably
today the most demanding religion really
reveals its face-to-face and reacts in a
different way so I know you've talked
about the regressive left and it start
for me Charlie Hebdo was the beginning
of my awakening and which happened over
the course of the next year or so but
what do you make of the group of people
and we had plenty of them here in the
United States and I'm sure you had
plenty of them in France as well people
on the Left people that are for women's
rights and for gay rights and for
minority rights that's suddenly when it
came to what happened with Charlie Hebdo
said ah you shouldn't have you know you
shouldn't have made fun of the the
cartoons you shouldn't have done these
cartoons talked about the Prophet
whatever it is people who otherwise are
totally for free speech and free
expression suddenly they're not in this
case so what do you make of those people
and how pervasive is that idea in France
these days well you said that it's all
started for you after Charlotte though I
think that it became so visible in
France as well after Charlotte dough and
recently also after cologne attacks in
Germany which we can also discuss not
only leftist but also feminist reaction
or feminist non reaction so I think that
yeah it's after these events we could
see this you know fraction of leftist
who would denied in the essential
problem who would be scared to talk
about the roots of the problem who will
who will be willing not to to talk about
Charlotte dah killers as people with
guns and not discuss their ideas and not
discuss what they were screaming while
shooting our friends what they were in
in the name of who they committed these
atrocities and what made them could
believe and then they have to do that
so I think that this is something again
which of course brings Europe in a very
big danger and especially the values of
Europe in a very big danger and
therefore I say that sometimes walking
in Paris I read these three words that
the slogan of French Revolution and I
understand that this is very far from
reality today from the society and of
course you hear the leaders the leftist
leaders here who try to you know make
speeches to defend freedom of expression
and make of Charlotte o heroes because
they're you know journalists who fell
down but they do not will they do not
want to discuss for which ideas they
they felt that for which ideas they were
killed so many of them you know of
course do it out of fear but very
different fear there is a very big fear
to be to have similar speech to
right-wing similar speech to actual
extent of bulbs and and racist right
such as from national with marine lepen
here in France
therefore leftist decided to take this
very ridiculous
again intellectually dishonest position
such as denying their roots and they you
know the real the essential problem in
this situation and I think this way the
betray also the ideas of shiny blue
office boys and of course yes so and at
the end of the result is that it's only
extreme right-wing the racist eccentric
center folks who are speaking out
actually yeah and this is this is what
I've said repeatedly here is that we on
the Left have to deal with this because
if we don't and this is exactly what
your piece in the International Business
Times was about if if the if we don't
deal with the regressive left then who
do we hand it to the racist right that
way that was your your turn
and I couldn't agree more so when you
say that France in terms of free speech
and people getting along would you say
France is in a worse position now do you
think that there was a net loss in free
speech after Charlie Hebdo because there
were a couple weeks after where the
whole world United and and you know all
those world leaders came to Paris and it
sounded like something good was gonna
happen but I sense you think it's
probably the reverse now well again
there are so many aspects to discuss
here this manifestation that happened
after 11th of January was ridiculous and
the the cartoonists who survived loose
for example who made the next cover with
Muhammad with Prophet crying we were
laughing with him in a parody it's
laughing because in front of him there
was a line of all the enemies of ideas
of Charlotte though and they were
marching you know again this event was
so full of hypocrisy because fact they
were marching at least this front line
were marching not for the not for the
right ideas you know they were
pretending they were yeah it was it was
fake I'm not talking about the million
of people who write out but I'm talking
about this front line which was totally
ridiculous and what happened after there
was so many events dedicated to
discussion of free speech which were
closed we were which were cancelled by
the government by police in order to you
know
for security reasons events in which me
myself was supposed to participate so
many of them were canceled again the
event that happened just one month after
in Copenhagen during which I was
speaking was interrupted by another
terrorist and again one person have been
killed it may have some injured so this
way you know again I think that we
failed after Charlotte though we failed
with all these ridiculous things such as
inviting
the representatives or those of those
who are feeding the terrorists those who
feed these ideas that are well actually
cannot coexist with ideas of freedom of
speech inviting them to Paris to March
for ideas of Charlotte though is
something that already showed that we
will fail in this discussion and I don't
want to make a conclusion that we did
fail but I feel we are failing here in
Europe the Europe is failing European
society is failing because they're not
ready to well to face very uncomfortable
very unpleasant but truth they are not
they are not able to hear unpopular
speech and if freedom of speech is
really about something if Liberty is
really something it's definitely about
unpopular speech it's about hearing
accepting this unpopular and comfortable
speech yeah and failing of doing that so
we only have a couple of minutes left I
know we're just getting into the meat of
this so we're good we're gonna have to
do this again where we can talk for much
longer but I hear you on the Europe part
and that's I get so much email now from
the same piece people saying the same
things in Denmark and in France and in
Germany and Finland all of these
countries people are saying the exact
same things that you're talking about
and they feel that there's no faith in
the government that the government's are
gonna do the right things and all of
that so so let's end on this so the
cologne event that that happened in
Germany with this it sounds like a
thousand men were running rampant
throughout the city and it's unclear if
they were all immigrants or migrants or
whatever it was the reaction to that
must have been particularly upsetting to
you because it dealt with sort of the
the free speech stuff and bringing all
these people in but it also directly
this was at a direct assault on women so
it really went to or everything that you
care about was the reaction to that
because I saw feminists that were not
defending the women I suddenly saw
feminists online well-known feminists
that were saying oh this is just an
excuse for the xenophobes and white men
do it too and all of those things so
that wasn't one must have been
particularly upsetting right well it was
yeah of course it was not only on not
only upsetting you know I think that
yeah today we use you look around and we
see that those who were supposed to be
your allies those who are supposed to
share with you with the very fundamental
values and stand for them either keep
silence or try to support actually your
aggressors the dresses of women just
because of the fact it was reported that
among the aggressors were men who looked
like Arabic men or North African origin
feminist silence they didn't want to
discuss what actually happened just
because of fear of again being you know
having the speech of extreme right-wing
and at the end who appeared to be actual
defenders of women you know who were
raped and aggressed
after cologne were extreme right-wing
again the platform was giving to them so
I think that to those people who write
you emails and to people who write me as
well a lot and who support who feel very
you feel betrayed sad by the situation
with that is going on today in Europe by
leftist reactions by the reaction some
of reaction of the feminists I think
that we have to understand that to be
sad is not enough to be sad you know
makes people cry and stay at home and
feel you know alone but what we have to
be many people don't like to face it but
what we have to be today we have to be
angry I think the anger brings people to
action not hate but anger anger for
defend you know for the fact that your
ideas are attacked that something very
essential for your life and joy of life
which people have today your opportunity
to enjoy life today here in Europe you
have to defend it and for that you have
to feel anger don't feel sad feel angry
act and defend your ideas and don't let
extreme right-wing write your own
history let's write it with our own
beautiful
and liberal ideas that's my message well
you know I don't even have to ask you a
final question because you couldn't have
ended this any better you absolutely
have an ally in me and I'm sure and much
of my audience so everyone can find more
Raveena's work at inna - Shevchenko comm
I thank you for joining me and we
absolutely will do this again because I
feel like we just we just touched the
surface of all this so thank you thank
you I appreciate it